michael jackson's oldest son Prince
Michael is working hard in the industry
as a producer but I was there last night
as the 19 year old took time out to give
back so my name is Prince Prince seems
to have that Jackson family star quality
he helped organize a holiday party for
deserving kids where does this come from
and you
well my father for kids from the Boys
and Girls Club of Los Angeles Harbor
were entertained by Disney characters
and receive gifts from Santa at the heel
la event prince co-founded the
organization at his school Loyola
Marymount University what's been the
most meaningful thing about seeing this
tonight um I think it's because when I
was younger my dad always told me about
how Disney was such a happy place and I
know that was kind of my dad and it's
good to know that I'm doing that for the
kids he's planning to spend the holidays
with his family over Thanksgiving 18
year old sister Paris posted this pic I
think she called you a stud muffin did
she I don't know if I saw that maybe she
blocked me for that picture hey no she
you know it was very sweet she said I'm
so oh my big brother yeah yeah yeah I
remember he's doing big things he's a
stud yeah we have a real funny
relationship and remember his little
brother blanket earlier Prince told me
he's changed his name so what do you
call your youngest brother what do you
call him do you call him blanket we call
him BG nobody's called him blanket I
can't write how long and he came up with
the nickname himself did he come yeah
and he just stuck
[Music]
you